hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone hanging
out at the South by Southwest Film
Festival and I'm joined by the campfire
by Bo Burnham and Elsie Fisher so warm
and toasty it's so good from eighth
grade director and start I was just
telling you that I loved seeing this
movie at Sundance and if I didn't know
that a guy had written it and directed
it I would never have been able to guess
because it reminded me so much of how I
felt and how awkward I felt at that age
and still kind of do so why did you want
to make this film I don't know I wanted
to write something about the internet
and how I was feeling at the time which
was nervous and and and my nerves felt
like they were connected to the Internet
somehow and so I sat down to write a
bunch of things and stumble in a voice
of this girl and found that I could say
everything I wanted through her I mean I
didn't sit down to write a story about a
13 year old girl because I wouldn't feel
qualified to but it was just a strange
thing when it started to happen it felt
like this feels very personal and right
to me and it feels like the best way to
talk about the current moment is through
someone that is really feeling the
current moment which is an eighth grader
yeah Elsie when you read the script
could you relate to that and also what
did you think about the social media
messages oh when I first read the script
I was really happy with the project
because all I'd really seen through
auditions was like the campfire scene
and then I didn't let her read the
script I laughed after she got the role
yeah I only let her rated once because I
didn't want her to overly yeah yeah yeah
no I was really hard to roll I was
really happy to see someone my age being
portrayed as like vulnerable and a very
relatable sense and not just oh god you
know I have so many problems I've no
friends yeah um you know and she just
she's a lot of internal struggle and
that was really cool for me
yeah and not a teenage girl would come
it takes off her glasses comes down the
stairs only super glamorous yeah yeah
it's not about that today it's about
putting the glasses on yeah it's a whole
difference thing all the difference well
it's given that it has so much about
social media in the film it was that
difficult to shoot mine yeah it was it
was it was his own challenge I mean we
tested a lot of it beforehand I mean the
real challenge was it was the internet
for the Internet we didn't do any screen
replacement or anything so like those
were actual Instagram accounts actual
Twitter accounts so we had to make we
had to make all these accounts they had
to make all the accounts to make them
follow her and then like when she's
deeming people on Instagram we just like
our Erica on props was just like
off-screen texting or in real-time it
was very stressful and granular and
annoying but I I hope it shows because
um I hate when they replaced screens and
movies I feel like I can always tell ya
and it's a hard thing to shoot ya just
well it's like it might look okay but
like the light coming off the phone
never looks right like when you scroll
through Instagram and you're looking
through different photos the light
actually changes on your face on your
thumbs we wanted that to actually happen
and the internet was a character that
she has a relationship with kind of so
it would have felt like you know like
the tennis ball and the hobbit the only
heavy heavy contact with the tennis ball
to not have we want it we wanted the
Internet to be in the movie playing
itself so and I love the fact that it's
it feels improvised the whole film even
though it was scripted because it's not
totally perfect there are moments when
characters stumble over words so how did
Bo direct you to help make that and feel
natural on-screen I mean you do you do a
laker really he does a really good job
of writing it and part of it was like
not letting me over read the script and
I would get the lines for the day on the
day of to keep it fresh in my mind
and it's it's just really
it's how like people talk yes so you
write with all the extra words in there
yeah yeah the arms and the hose and the
likes and really just telling her you
know you can't make a mistake you know
the only mistake you could make is is
being you know prodigiously articulate
which isn't a problem for you know it's
I told her I didn't say a complete
sentence and I was 24 you know this is
about someone struggling to articulate
themselves when you're that age you
don't know how to string words together
so if you stumble or you forget a line
or you go with it she's she's constantly
not knowing what to say she's constantly
forgetting the lines she had in her mind
when she's approaching this boy across
the hallway you know but she has an
incredible gift for memorization you
know she can read one thing and memorize
it right away but we always kind of
stood on that sort of 95 percent
memorize sort of place just so there
could be a we were always in danger of
losing it which it just keeps it keeps
it alive yeah it does it feels a little
bit unpredictable like you never know
what's going to happen and this is a
super film nor anything to say but I
heard you were influenced by Katherine V
yeah yeah they do have that yeah I mean
it's incredible well her films are just
so really just filled moment to moment
and not necessarily in the most danger
the whole thing is just dangerous just
the way in which things are being
captured is dangerous where it feels
like you really really don't know what's
coming and you're not really even sure
how to process the person you're seeing
is this something am i okay to laugh at
this am i sympathizing with this and
yeah um but yeah she she was a huge
influence of mine Marisa silver also
made this film old enough that is redoes
a little younger than 13 really really
well
it's rare that movies George Washington
you know that film as well that that
allows the sort of inner chaos of a kid
to express itself on on screen you know
rather than like movies about little
poet laureates that are so articulate
about their own experience I always find
that so lame you know I don't relate to
that at all when you know it's like
being a kid and being a human is not
knowing what to say ever yeah well I'll
see you with the breakout star at
Sundance everyone was talking about her
yeah everyone was like who is this girl
and she's front center of this amazing
film so what is your whole journey been
like since Sundance in our South by
um seriously just been going back to
school and no one cares really yeah I
got a public school and like the only
you know people that know I exist as an
actress is my theater class because I
didn't get a role in my school play oh I
got back she she was in eighth grade
graduated did the movie and then went to
freshman year yeah and she didn't get
cast in a school play
so I publicly called out her mister Dona
from Thousand Oaks High School should be
fired him calling out calling don't you
out for the whole all of his classes
I know but yeah you know Thousand Oaks I
don't think they're big 8:24 fans I
don't think everyone at Thousand Oaks
High School is watching the lobster and
would shock you know and then they'll
say we always knew you always knew yeah
yeah
mr. Dona was just testing you know it's
like Jordan not making is a penalty
[Music]
you
[Music]